dass ich noch so finde ich höre ich aber
findest du irgendwas ada re batterie ich
brauche dafür tdl super bitte nach re -
b kümmer dich darum betreibers conny
weißt du was sollten wir vielleicht für
die erste zeit zusammen ziehen ja wäre
ich dann auch für weil das wird das
alles durcheinander weißt du was sonst
die zu dir und bauen die erst mal deinen
haus hier dass hier das hier bauen wir
erstmal okay ja immer du dich mal bitte
darum sucht mal dass im chat batterie
das ist das was du brauchst dann kümmere
ich mich um den in den generator mit
sinn und blabla jolo ja darauf an dass
da haben die materialien außer den
koffer cable und festkörper cable
brauchen wir aber also ich habe jetzt
ein entferntes und 5 1 teilen wir noch
einmal ganz kurz nach generator suchst
dann schießt er das rezept von einem
generator der für den generator brauchen
wir auf jeden fall dass opel zumindest
ein entferntes den habe ich drei bin
habe ich auch und die batterie brauchen
wir auf die batterie kann man allerdings
nie irgendwie nicht draufklicken
deswegen wende zum und chats batterie
und dann auf drauf ticks daran hast du
ja wir haben wir genug da musst du in
der red sondern wir auf jeden anlass ist
nur ein rapper cable das heißt man habe
nur noch aber finden besser
ich gebe es einen rabatt suchen aber
kannst auch einfachste crazy verbrennen
hamm ist die core i7 ich weiß ist die
krise ist ihnen hatte ja nee nee ist die
chinesen ist bienen harz wir haben
standhafte throne um bienen hat kommt
aus verpackten bienen herz und das kommt
wiederum und 5
wir brauchen erwin haas wie kriegt man
im bienenhaus vielleicht müssen wir mal
so ein blog der abbau aber ich darum
seine komische unseren bühnen dingsbums
abzubauen auch man bestimmten gegen
genauso im köcher oder so schnell einmal
köcher
kesha dienen
hier gibt es ganz viele bienen ziegler
bienenhaus wien rohr verpackte
bienenhaus seidiges wie macht man ein
bisschen werkzeug brauchen dafür nach
ich bin überfordert konnten schreibt
weißt du was ist eine debatte aber ich
weil ich weiß dass ich viel verpasst
aber willst du hier sind jetzt insgesamt
16 mini modernes reicht für 2 weißt du
diese mini moke scherben die kann man zu
diesen minimum stein machen und die mini
umstadt ii kam für jedes item - das
heißt ich könnte das minimal schneller
machen
ich könnte auch obsidian das macht alles
ausmachen wir werden aber obsidian uns
machen wir ob sie dazu schwer zu
bekommen
wobei wenn wir drei dir ihr könnt auch
versuchen einen diamanten daraus zu
machen
heute kann man jemanden raus kräften
aber ich habe ja diamanten das heißt
vereinfacht auch diamant moment
eigentlich ist es sinnvoller da draußen
diamanten zu machen weil wir haben ja
drei diamanten könnten uns eine
spitzhacke machen dann können wir eh
obsidian abbauen annehmen kann man kann
leider keinen diamanten aus - und das
wäre schade man kann ob sie die an so
herstellen
das ist schade wirklich schade
ok dann würde ich einfach mal sagen soll
licht ist jetzt auch so kommen so
erstmal gehen
naja warten jetzt einfach mal betten
hier in den ställen irgendwie doch wolle
und alles was eine rolle und buchholz
für mich auch zum übernachten bei dir
ich hätte nicht guckt dich unbedingt
kisten du kannst du einfach dem bett
eben holen ich hole einfach oben ich
darf jetzt auch mit von rüdiger muss ja
in der nähe der grödiger wollen ich
werde beim sein ist eigentlich stimmen
kann ich ruhiger in etwas mutiger bleibt
leben bis folge hunderte dann springe
ich natürlich alles in die luft so wie
sich das gehört ja wir sind jetzt in
waltrop dem weiter auf mysteriöse art
und weise
jetzt wo die kritiker
ich bin auch mit und die leute die sich
beschweren dass ich wie kannst du jetzt
erst nicht so unglücklich
also ich hab hunger und er ist hawass
ich habe hier nur wasser so hörst du
mich ja okay das skelett na denn der
mann aus tod eindeutig was zu essen und
ich habe glaube ich sogar irgendwo was
so also kümmerst du dich eben wie ein
roboter rhabarber kriegt man ja auch in
sachen das heißt wir müssen einen
kescher kriegen ich habe ja sogar sonst
ein komisches bienen item
mehr weiß ich wo willst du gerade
ich bin mit meiner bergsiedlung of
destiny und ja wenn ich bin machen wir
gerade hier
ich hole jetzt ruhen oder als herunter
und ich stehe zu dir
weil wir müssen direkt machen den habe
ich mache jetzt hier los war
hinten ist ein krieg er denkt sie auch
so jolo sprechen wir das ganze haus egal
ich muss mein weg stellen bringen ein
bett mit am besten wieder runterkommen
station macht bmw 4
ich schlafe und bringt fackeln mit damit
werde das irgendwie ein bisschen
ausgleichen können guck mal guckt mal
mein bett steht
schöne nacht eine romantische freundin
schon voll
so jetzt aber versucht richtig echt
scheiße mit hunger in wien aufzunehmen
egal alter eigentlich wollte ich hab in
ordnung ein machen also die gleichen
gesten lager machen
ich wollte es einfach alles erst mal
hier rein und dann werde ich einfach
jetzt gleich mal sortieren stein und
ärzte damit wir mal überblick haben was
wir ja sortiert du erstmal das ist ganz
gut ist natürlich einfach mal und ich
erzähle was wird das lässt ja auch
spannend bleibt und spannend wird also
was wir was mir immer wieder auffällt
wird das ansprechen was ihm auffällt ist
es immer wieder sachen auf 1
das team warte mal ganz gestern zwischen
sache worüber wollten was wollten wir
um was wollten uns jetzt kümmern also
ein genie und freundes habe ich den habe
ich wollte überholen also für den ort
kabel genau dann musst du dich auf jeden
fall noch mal ganz klipp gucken wie die
und kesha bekommst nein ich werde trees
abbauen
robert tri sestri sind mal ganz kurz das
war ein
ja ja ich weiß wir sind glaube ich aber
wie krieg ich da mache ich das aus
bienen hartstock oder die chinesin das
klima nur aus dem harz er zeigt ich doch
verdammt ich schauen wir schon mal ganz
kurz viel kriegt man acht mann braucht
sogar electric phoenix glaube ich habe
meine fördert und keine elektrik für uns
electric hoeneß also dafür braucht man
einen pornofilms dann redstone und ein
elektronik circuit
dafür brauchen wir brauchen für kopper
cable und wir brauchen vorbilder bei uns
aber kopper in gott haben würde
ja ja keine ahnung wie kommt ihr opfer
schreibt in kommentare wie kommission an
robbe
koffer koffer koffer tenor eisenerz da
kommt heuer das werde ich erst mal ein
bisschen brutzeln noch im kopf
alles was du vorhast oder so einfach
schenken
ich hab nur 12 ich sag dir einfach
einfach alles in kisten
ich hab ne 12 kupfer ewig anders sehen
weil ich noch irgendwo kupfer bronze
bronze ist bronze kupfer nehme oder
persönlich so was ist sonst noch so
alles immer links ist morgens im cooper
s coupé das war die spielweise des tages
james soll wieder ein
es heißt und morgen deutschland sie sich
zum narren hält chart habe ich hier
jetzt bringt es auch nichts erspart
smaragdgrün chirurgie an kunden des
marktes für meine werkzeuge bauen
damit möchte ich mal sehen können was
man für neue werkzeug jetzt machen kann
man kann japan liegt dann kann ich erst
den aus den bunten kristallen kann man
nämlich zb rubin schwerter ruppin hacke
und welche sachen kann man was man hat
aus rubinen und sowas kann man so
richtig leiden schwerte uns was bauen
versuch erst mal hier irgendwie links er
beinahe gleich mein januarwoche auch
werkzeug und werkzeug nicht aus dem
eisen bauen weil es eben brauchen wir
für unsere ganzen sachen und im disco
von sony was ich ja auch nicht weiß ich
hab eine standhafte drohne ja genau das
weiß auch nicht was das macht mein
interesse team oder gar nicht können die
ihnen sonst suchen
wohin wo bist du hinten sind das war
patrice nein
aber was da oben auf dem baum hängt
was hängen haben muss jetzt mal ganz
kurz wir müssen glaube ich wieder
phangan jedoch nicht sondern eine
optische illusion
wo willst du hin
ich habe da hinten da da hängt was darum
auch nicht an pils ach ich bin geistig
stark erwartet so ich wollte mal ganz
kurz nämlich was zeigen dass es noch zu
früh